it's time for another game spot news
update and today we're talking about how
the witcher 3 wild hunts newest patch
will improve the game for all players
sadly still no news of the garel
bathtime dlc bagalkot out CD Projekt RED
is working on a new witcher 3 patch that
will among other things address
performance on playstation 4 and
implement a range of new bug fixes
writing on the game's forums community
manager marcin marmots said the upcoming
patch number 1.09 will include a massive
number of changes though the full list
of tweaks has not yet been published he
explained that the patch is on the way
and that the changelog looks really
impressive he responded to questions
about the unannounced release date by
asking for a bit more patience releasing
the patch in October alongside the
witcher threes first expansion hearts of
stone would seem likely but this is not
confirmed hearts of stone which will add
another 10 hours of gameplay onto those
dozens of hours I already poured in
launches on October 13th have you had
any entertaining glitches or bugs that
you'll be sad to see go are you looking
forward to Garrett bath time or maybe
you just like to let us know what you're
looking forward to in the patch let us
know in the comments below I'm Kate you
can follow me on twitter at how not to
draw and make sure to keep it gamespot
com for all your which are 3 News